Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This episode is about a really nice new paper
on pose estimation.
Pose estimation means that we have an image
or video of a human as an input, and the output
should be, this skeleton that you see here
that shows us what the current position of
this person is.
Sounds alright, but what are the applications
of this, really?
Well, it has a huge swath of applications,
for instance, many of you often hear about
motion capture for video games and animation
movies, but it is also used in medical applications
for finding abnormalities in a patient’s
posture, animal tracking, understanding sign
language, pedestrian detection for self-driving
cars, and much, much more.
So if we can do something like this in real
time, that’s hugely beneficial for many
many applications.
However, this is a very challenging task,
because humans have a large variety of appearances,
images come in all kinds of possible viewpoints,
and as a result, the algorithm has to deal
with occlusions as well.
This is particularly hard, have a look here.
In these two cases, we don’t see the left
elbow, so it has to be inferred from seeing
the remainder of the body.
We have the reference solution on the right,
and as you see here, this new method is significantly
closer to it than any of the previous works.
Quite remarkable.
The main idea in this paper is that it works
out the poses both in 2D and 3D and contains
neural network that can convert to both directions
between these representations while retaining
the consistencies between them.
First, the technique comes up with an initial
guess, and follows up by using these pose
transformer networks to further refine this
initial guess.
This makes all the difference.
And not does it lead to high-quality results,
but it also takes way less time than previous
algorithms — we can expect to obtain a predicted
pose in about 51 milliseconds, which is almost
20 frames per second.
This is close to real time, and is more than
enough for many of the applications we’ve
talked about earlier.
In the age of rapidly improving hardware,
these are already fantastic results both in
terms of quality and performance, and not
only the hardware, but the papers are also
improving at a remarkable pace.
What a time to be alive.
The paper contains an exhaustive evaluation
section, it is measured against a variety
of high-quality solutions, I recommend that
you have a look in the video description.
I hope nobody is going to install a system
in my lab that starts beeping every time I
slouch a little, but I am really looking forward
to benefitting from these other applications.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!